i feel like i've spent this entire
vacation
walking this is what tourism looks like
during the coronavirus pandemic
it's very busy most roads
that's the biggest crowd i've been in
since lockdown began i am lost and i am
hot
as countries reopen their borders again
after lockdowns i wanted to see if it
was possible to travel safely
this is actually a really lovely way to
get around the city
so with my editor's permission i took a
short trip from london to barcelona
but getting here while feeling safe and
relaxed wasn't as easy as it used to be
here's what i learned first off
i want to know if travelling is a good
idea at all so i called elena cyric an
environmental microbiologist
lena do you think it's safe to travel
right now it is safe to travel
it is a risk but i think if you're wise
and you use
a mask well and you keep you know
washing your hands
i think it should be okay lane has
agreed to be my virtual tour guide
helping to ensure that i don't catch or
spread the virus while i'm traveling
i think the measures that have been
imposed by various governments have
evolved a bit over time in a way we've
become more aware and we now know
better how to deal with this step one is
picking somewhere to go
something that i found easy in the past
but is now difficult a great resource is
the us state department's website which
has information on rules for each
country
traveling to spain for a holiday for
example is not something you can
currently do from the us
but i'm allowed to go from london as
many countries in europe have loosened
restrictions after months of lockdowns
i have to fill out this contact tracing
health form before i go
you'll find that some other countries
have a similar approach it's also
important to check for specific public
health guidelines like mandatory
quarantines in any countries you might
be traveling through
unpacking my suitcase isn't as simple as
just sunscreen and sandals
i would probably have about 10 reusable
masks
definitely stock up on some hand
sanitizer might be worth taking some
surface wipes
i'm taking two types of masks with me
these homemade cloth masks will be used
when i'm outdoors in
uncrowded spaces but these are n95
medical grade masks
and these will be used when i'm in
crowded or confined
public spaces my employer has said i
have to use this when traveling
oh that is not comfortable
okay first impressions it's very it's
very clean
at the airport baggage drop and security
were similarly clean
with plenty of opportunities for me to
sanitize my hands
but it's hardly a relaxing experience
wandering around an airport where there
are huge signs warning you of the virus
at every turn
i'm sorry the game right now and i've
just done an announcement that says the
flight is full
big big queues just fought
everyone just rushed to the gate to
board now everyone's bunched over there
there was a lot of people rushing to try
and get
through the gate it's very busy
uh most rows quite full that's possibly
because while the number of inter-europe
flights has risen some 42
since june it's still a fraction of how
many were flying pre-pandemic
british airways who i'm flying with says
it adheres to all guidance from
governments and regulators
according to elena the air quality in
here could be the safest of my entire
journey
from the point of view of air and
ventilation planes really
are probably your safest mode of
transport the air quality in there is
probably the best that you'd find
in you know in any mode of transport and
probably in most
indoor spaces not only do they add about
50
fresh air but it's also hepa filtered
and and hepa filters are
basically the gold standard when it
comes to air filtration it's just that
you're stuck there for
some time with other people after my
plane lands i have to pass through
barcelona airport's coved control gate
i had to show them a qr code from the
form that i filled out i didn't have my
temperature taken as i went through
spain's ministry of health says that
sometimes people are not aware their
temperature is being taken by thermal
cameras
i have never been happier to walk into a
hotel room
at my hotel there are sanitizing
stations throughout and a one-way system
in place
i can finally
take my mask off for the first time
properly in about three four hours
oh but i can't relax just yet
things like bedside tables maybe it's a
good idea to give those a little bit of
a wipe
but then things like light switches and
handles
and remote controls so just the things
that
is probably won't have been cleaned
thoroughly
popping a do not disturb sign on the
door should mean that nobody else comes
in
but you'll have to forgo a turndown i
was also told that breakfast would be
served in my room instead of the usual
buffet
sightseeing also involves following a
number of rules that vary from place to
place
even though i'm not in a crowded area
i'm still wearing a mask right now
that's partly for my own safety and for
the safety of others
but also it's because if you get caught
without a mask
on the street in spain there's an
instant 100 euro five
it's worth checking with local
authorities to find out what the rules
are at your destination to stay
safe i decide to walk most of the time i
think it would be a good idea
to avoid going on public transport
really if you can
on public transport there's many more
people that go through there
i i would say there is a bit more risk
going on a train because it's less
controlled because the ventilation
system
isn't isn't as sophisticated as it would
be on a plane
walking is nice but it does take away
precious time from my weekend break
i feel like i've spent this entire
vacation walking between the things i
want to see
rather than just enjoying things if you
go by taxi i mean it again it really
depends
on the taxi driver to some extent you
know are they cleaning between people
do they keep their windows open i'm
gonna do down the window if that's okay
yeah yeah thank you sir were the
passengers that were in there
before you did they wear masks were they
careful
it's a bit of a gamble i used a taxi to
get from the airport to the hotel
but for long journeys in the city i
choose to hire a bike
and just carefully wipe down the
handlebars with sanitizer
this is actually a really lovely way to
get around the city
i feel clean i feel safe i've got fresh
air
i'm actually making quite a bit of
progress an hour and a half's ride costs
me eight dollars
the virus has even impacted how i dine
for restaurants we've got
two alarm bells potentially lots of
people
potentially an indoor area with quite a
few people in it
so if possible and weather permitting
stick to a table outside if you can that
might be quite easy here and that's for
two reasons
firstly spain enjoys a nice climate and
dining outside
is part of the culture here but secondly
because the government have decreed that
you can open your restaurant if
you have a terrace area where people can
dine so people don't have to go indoors
one venue that was allowed to reopen was
a nearby tapas bar owned by yuri van
rossi and his partner
i think it was three weeks only only the
places with terraces could open
so we were one of the lucky ones for
buzz like yuri's even if local residents
are going out again
there's a lot riding on getting
travellers to come back
we work mainly with tourism and some
let's say about 70 percent of tourism
and 30 local people
barcelona without tourism just doesn't
work
tourist attractions like the sagrada
familia basilica were closed during my
stay
the crux of the problem is that
vacations are supposed to be relaxing
and it's kind of hard to relax in the
midst of a global pandemic the mask
wearing hand sanitizing and constant
reminders of the virus
don't exactly make for a relaxing trip
but for now some of these measures are
just the reality of travelling
safely and most governments and health
experts
don't expect this to change anytime soon
it's worth remembering that
for now it's impossible to completely
eliminate the risk of the virus
so if you're not comfortable traveling
it's probably best to stay at home